[Musique]
oh
e
[Musique]
oh
et voilà donc à peu près à quoi
ressemble la légende de zelda une
question
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est tout ça il ya plein
de truies sinon c'est génial regarde son
téléphone une facture téléphonique on en
voyait que ça fuller une photo de mon
voisin avec sa femme mais alors on reste
que j'ai atterri
[Musique]
le monde c'est reparti pour une nouvelle
vidéo est aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je vais
exaucé un de vos rêves puisque en fait
je vais tester le jeu
d'ailleurs c'est le jeu je crois qu'il a
été le plus demandé c'est pas seulement
un beau région en fête
là où ça devient criminel c'est que
c'est un mauvais jeu qui a ruiné qui a
souillé une saga qui avance a été
magique
non sérieusement legend of zelda c'est
certainement la série de jeux vidéo la
plus connue au monde on a tous zelda
préféré beaucoup de gens vous diront que
c'est ocarina of time qui a vraiment
marqué l'entrée dans l'ère moderne des
zelda - personnes ont préféré c'est
link's awakening et zelda surtout c'est
quand même une série de jeux vidéo qui a
été sans faute
tous les jeux zelda même ceux qui
étaient très dures étaient géniaux bref
tout était parfait et personne n'aurait
pu imaginer la suite des événements
jusqu'à ce jour d'octobre 93 par un
temps de pluie dans une prairie
abandonné la franchise de zelda a été
sauvagement violée à trois reprises les
coupables
les voici les titres joueur du grenier a
voulu en savoir plus sur ce crime atroce
et c'est un reportage que nous vous
proposons ling faith of evil et zelda ou
en off gamelon et oui j'ai dit et ville
et je vous emmerde sortie sur la cd i de
philips une console sortie en france à
92 pour l'histoire donc normalement
philips et sony était en course pour
créer un support cd pour la super nes
exactement comme pour la mega cd avec la
megadrive mais l'accord n'a pas abouti
sony finalement choisira de développer
sa propre console qui deviendra la
playstation quelques années plus tard et
pareil pour philips qui a recyclé son
idée en fait dans une console à part qui
s'appelle la phillips cdi
malgré l'échec du contrat en fait
phillips a quand même gardé le droit
selon le contrat d'exploiter un jeu
mario et 3 jeux zelda normalement à la
base la console a été surtout fait pour
les jeux éducatifs mais beaucoup de
jeunes au rebond et effet dessus et
beaucoup de grosses merdes au passage
bref ces jeux même si vous y avez pas
jouer vous les avez peut-être vu au
moins une fois sur internet puis sans
peine les cinématiques de ce jeu sont
tellement connue pour être moche et mal
foutu qu'elles sont devenues célèbres
dans les livres ou tubes poupe ce jeu
d'ailleurs c'est un but passage obligé
pour tous les testeurs du net
donc il est réputé pour être mauvais
alors bon je vais perdre rien vous
apprendre de neuf tout a déjà été dit
dessus en tout cas ce coup ci c'est à
mon tour de m'amuser sans qu'est-ce
qu'on peut s'ennuyer ici mon petit cet
ep ce pour quoi luttent tous les vrais
guerriers
je me demande ce que canon est en train
de faire votre majesté canons et ses
fidèles se sont emparés de l'île de
corrida que pouvons nous faire
il est écrit seul linke peut vaincre
gannon
c'est génial je prends mes affaires ok
alors stop alors déjà pour commencer
l'aïe a marqué rien du tout poisson rien
du tout ensuite gannon canon gagnent au
ghana ce qu'ils gagnent on est la bouche
de plus longtemps alors oui c'est bah
c'est peut-être lui mais l'ennemi
s'appelle ganon paganon oui et tu es un
dernier truc aussi
ah oui pourquoi sur images n'étaient
cieux mais regardez-moi soit enfin mais
même si j'arrête image par image chômage
à cause d'un truc affreux et un petit
baiser pour me porter chance
civ mais c'est dingue et plaisanter mais
c'est quoi ce truc sa coupe au sinon au
niveau de la voix ce jeu c'est le
premier ou nantes en ligne par laisser
la vente un tintin d'ailleurs un si
mauvais pas reconnu c'est cool non
et c'est aussi le dernier où il parle et
c'est pas plus mal en fait h
mais voilà moi ta gueule en fait ce
n'est pas vraiment un problème de voix
c'est plus un problème de textes à mon
avis voilà en fait vous aurez peut-être
fait le rapprochement d'ailleurs si vous
avez vu mon sujet sur les adaptations de
jeux vidéo en dessin animé
mais je pense qu'il ya des chances qu'en
fait ce jeu soit adapté du dessin animé
ldap
il retrouve un peu le même genre de link
comme fabriquer de zelda un peu garçon
manqué et je suis vraiment désolé
française
d'ailleurs comme preuve dans le second
jeu zelda sur cd ou en off gamme lancé
zelda qui prend les paie et qui part
sauver league
d'ailleurs la cinématique d'intro est
encore plus horrible au passage je tard
pour gamelon pour l'été moi j'aime
beaucoup les mouvements du roi en fait
c'est pas des zooms c'est lui qui
distribue frais qu'il est sur des patins
à roulettes protéger si dans un mois je
n'ai pas donné signe de vie après c'est
sûr
gano ne fait pas le poids contre le roi
par pur gamme l'eau et trouve mon père
super je suis impatient de bombarder les
taux 2 go
[Musique]
attends les guides explosé bon allez
revenons au jeu donc maintenant alors le
jeu link face-off et ville commence donc
évidemment sans explication on a le
choix entre trois niveaux
donc j'ai choisi complètement par hasard
celui de la neige parce que rien
n'indique lequel il faut prendre au
passage donc on ramasse des boules de
neige mais qui ne servent à rien ah ben
oui aussi j'ai oublié de te dire un truc
c'est que j'ai beau avoir cherché
partout dans mes cartons je n'arrive pas
à retrouver ma manette de cdi donc
histoire de rajouter du délire à ce test
je suis obligé de jouer avec une manette
de base qui est pourri et qui est pas du
tout adapté à ce genre de jeu ouais
[Musique]
le jeu se joue donc à la façon de zelda
2 comme side scroller on navigue entre
les niveaux en passant par une carte du
monde
alors bon déjà je suis pas vraiment un
grand fan de des zelda en vue de côté
mais alors là ce jeu ça m'a achevé
détesté ça mais moi ce qui m'a le plus
gonflé mais j'ai très largement dans ce
jeu c'est le bouclier dans les zelda
récents ou dans link's awakening par
exemple avait un bouton qui te permet de
brandir le bouclier mais là le système
ça fonctionne un peu de manière show où
on dira un genre de mix entre zelda 1 2
et 3 c'est à dire qu'en fait le bouclier
ne s'active que quand tu immobile alors
sur le fond le principe n'est pas ultra
mauvais ça marchait plutôt bien dans
zelda 2 et ça marchait quand le bouclier
s'activent immédiatement un paquet mais
deux [ __ ] de secondes a levé son bras
non mais vous le voyez là dès que je
suis en mouvement et que je m'arrête en
fait que le tram de qu'une seconde
pratiquement ou ligne ne bouge plus ou
le bouclier restent baissés
ben franchement là je vous jure que
cette seconde sept petites secondes elle
va vous faire chier des cactus parce que
toutes mes mort pratiquement c'était à
cause de cinq noms mais je veux dire est
ce que vous trouvez ça normal de voir
avancer mètre par mètre comme ça sérieux
tout ce que je fais de le faire en
prenant en compte qui est un lac sur le
bouclier aval va se [ __ ]
j'ai trouvé une clé qui ouvre la porte
et est ok les ennemis sont invincibles
donc j'ai fait tout ça pour rien on va
passer une bonne journée
bon allez je prends un autre niveau je
galère je crève une fois je crève deux
fois je crève trois fois je recommence
je m'énerve je vais tuer des chiens dans
la rue pour me passer les nerfs jeu mais
n'ont jamais fait ça mais enfin une
ruche où une avenue bref j'arrive au
bout finalement et à l'intérieur tout
est noir on voit que dalle
ok donc évidemment si j'essaie d'avancer
je suis bloqué ya squales à la qui me
dit d'aller voir goreux nous regardes et
tu vas voir grenoux ok mais en fait
gourou c'est exactement l'endroit où je
suis tête de gland c'est incroyable
pourquoi est ce que donne tous les rpg
il ya toujours des abrutis comme ça
salut à toi joie trop le punch mais
enfin bref donc bien je prends le
dernier niveau elle jusqu'à plus que je
suis là
donc il ya une bonne femme qui dit un
truc avec un accent parisien
incompréhensible des dairas sortait du
cratère jusqu'à ce que je bouche le trou
j'ai utilisé un crâne comme pérou est
pas une des rats n'a réussi à le
comprendre
nintendo les boîtes de thon le petit
navire présentes lignes face-off édiles
bon soit donc j'avance je vais au bout
du niveau je trouve la cabane d'un vieux
pêcheur ils me donnent la master sword
ensuite je retourne sur mes pages attend
enfin vieux pêcheur qui vit de me donner
la master sword
c'est un vieux pêcheur dans une cabane
en ruine qui vient de me donner la
master sword l'épée la plus puissante
dans le jeu zelda chez les plus gros
crac que j'ai jamais attrapé mais c'est
un gars m'a tuer plutôt du bruit
[Applaudissements]
explication la quinta angel écrin bah
tiens voilà les payer john deere bon tu
me dire ah non c'est vrai c'est qu'un
détail quelque part mais est ce genre de
détails franchement c'est comme la
moustache de végéta quoi c'est
supportable
et puis en plus elle master sans le
monde qu elle a master show et permet de
tirer des lasers quand tu as to take her
mais dans ce jeu de merde t'as jamais to
take her dans un zelda normal tu trouves
des coeurs un peu partout sur les
monstres en cassant des objets
mais ici à rien n'y a aucun objet a
cassé et aucun monstre de la chaleur
aucun même dans zelda 2 tu croises et
des faits un peu partout mais là y'a
rien le premier objet pour gagner de
l'énergie s'est croisé au bout de huit
heures de jeu au latin et moi je suis
toujours perdu en plus là je sais pas où
il faut aller mais la neige c'est bloqué
la caverne s'est bloqué le volcan ya
rien à l'aï depuis tout à l'heure je
tourne en rond partout dans le jeu là en
écoutant la musique de merde de ce jeu
lorsque wii ce jeu a vraiment des
musiques de merde quoi jeudi alors ça me
fait mal de dire ça franchement parce
que la musique de zelda sont magnifiques
d'habitude mais là les musiques dans ce
jeu mais c'est le suppositoire musicale
quoi on fait du disque en fait pour être
précis si j'étais en 1984 dans une boîte
de nuit qui s'appellerait le macumba
night je pourrais peut-être
éventuellement trouver ça comme étant de
la bonne musique donc de vol là alors
que je suis en train de jouer un jeu
vidéo sur zelda et je trouve ca
légèrement hors sujet en fait allé une
autre c'était
[Musique]
mais vraiment ça me fait gravement
penser aux musiques des années 80 alors
pourtant le jeu et des sorties de 10 ans
après j'aimerais bien savoir comment ils
ont réagi chez nintendo quand ils ont vu
ça bon alors sérieusement je comprends
rien à ce jeu je vois pas ce qu'il faut
faire
normalement la cgt dans un jeu vidéo
c'est à ce moment là que quelque chose
de vraie bd savoir parler le hibou
réfléchissons il doit y avoir une naine
10 dans les dialogues et des rats
sortait du cratère jusqu'à ce que je
bouche le trou alors dd rhin sortait du
cratère donc rat race est le dieu du
soleil
le soleil c'est la vie pour vivre on a
besoin de calcium le calcium fortifie
les eaux les hausses que l'aide cram
squelette voilà c'est ça il faut taper
le crâne du scala c'était évident à aa
[Musique]
voilà donc évidemment j'arrive dans la
grotte du volcan en fait il fallait
deviner que ce crâne la bloquer la porte
ici quand bien même il y avait 2 mètres
entre les deux métiers maintenant les
boules de neige le servent enfin il est
roi et de ce jeu en fait c'est de devoir
utiliser les boules de neige pour tuer
les ennemis de feu et les boules de feu
pour tuer les ennemis de classe
alors bon le concept j'aurais pu être
intéressant en fait si l'aube où nombre
de boules a récolté n'était pas
totalement exagéré en fait la moitié du
jeu je ne montre pas mais la moitié du
jeu environ consiste à tourner en rond
dans les zones de glace et de feu pour
fermer les boules et je peux vous
affirmer que ces méga lourd de devoir
fermer tous les deux niveaux et c'est
pareil pour les rubis en fait parce
qu'on n'a jamais autant eu besoin de
rumi que dans ce zelda en fait les bons
beaucoup d'imprimés hallucinant vers lui
pour trois bombes et surtout tous les
objets coûte des rubis à l'utilisation
sinon pour parler un peu des graphismes
si on enlève les horribles vidéo ben
c'est pas les quand même faut l'avouer
le style tout en essaim des décors c'est
assez joli
par contre ça pose un autre gros
problème c'est pour les plateformes pour
savoir où elles sont en fait ils font
s'est jamais réellement marché je dire
qu'est-ce qui fait partie du décor et
qu'est-ce qui est une plateforme
bâtonnets en voilà une là un rocher
arrondi oui le début de la plateforme
est-ce que c'est là où est ce que c'est
la wii mais surpasse à travers allez
allez deuxième essai même chose à la
sortie où il a fait de la plateforme
elle est là au sérieux ce jeu mais ça me
déprime quoi je vais devenir gothique
lave à la fin de la vidéo ça continue
bon sinon autre chose
est-ce que j'ai vraiment besoin de
préciser que ce jeu est affreusement
difficile chaque zone est composé de
trois six tableaux différents remplis
d'ennemis chaque fois que tu meurs je
reviens au début du tableau en cours et
au bout de trois morts c'est cuit qui
revient sur la carte du monde et a plus
qu'un tour faire alors dit comme ça ça a
l'air facile mais à l'usure tu es obligé
de crever même en faisant hyper
attention déjà comme j'ai dit à cause du
fait que tu trouve quasiment jamais
aucun moyen de remonter pour l'énergie
mais surtout à cause du fait que les
ennemis
il y en a partout sa repop en boucle ça
s'arrête jamais c'est supportable
en fait vraiment il ya tellement
d'ennemis volant dans ce jeu que je vous
jure que c'est vrai pas non contesté le
jeu j'ai pété le bouton o d'une de mes
télécommande de saisie j'ai vraiment pas
fait exprès un sans déconner alors bon
j'en ai bien trouver une deuxième mais
manque de bol je les égards et aussi
chez paou ouellet est finie
bon bah c'est celle qui en a trouvé une
qui marche à la la qu'est ce que je
ferais sans lui retour au jeu le vrai
plaisir d'ailleurs avec les ennemis
volants par exemple sur les
chauves-souris ou sur les ptérodactyles
c'est que leur hit box en fait elle est
située juste sur la tête ça veut dire
qu'elle situe les frappes sur 90
pourtant du corps tu n'es tu pas est
obligé de les taper bile sur la tronche
et puis bon il utilise vraiment
n'importe quoi comme excuse pour avoir
des ennemis volants dans tous les
niveaux dans un autre niveau qui
s'appelle firestone comme la marque de
pneus et bien les ennemis cdc des pneus
voilà des pneus enflammés qui volent et
à tête chercheuse au 6 et des pneus
enflammés qui volent à tête chercheuse
voilà c'est normal que tu vas chercher
le lien avec l'univers de zelda là
vraiment je veux dire il ya ce coin là
là au début du niveau là il veut pas
l'emmener en bas ou le dren branlée en
plus le level design vraiment il a été
fait par des vieux cochons parce qu'il
ya des endroits où c'est hyper vicieux
genre là juste au moment où tu arrives
près de l'échelle talent et machin qui
apparaissent donc toi du couvent est
appuyé sur ol pourtant sauté pour moi
les tuer sauf que non on appuie un sirop
ça te fait monter à l'échelle je veux
pas monter à l'échelle et on sait jamais
au cas où tu arrives en euros il ya
quand même un ennemi qui te balance des
trucs en étant hors de l'écran super bon
allez c'est reparti non non non non non
non non non non non non mais comment tu
me djiby de ça je suis dans le jeu
depuis deux secondes je n'aime pas
fermer ta le dinosaure qui me plante je
suis le mec qui me lance dès sa droite à
noël dans la tronche aller au tas
regarde moi ça j'ai fait deux mètres
j'ai déjà plein coeur quoi merde allez
cette fois je fonce je fonce bon eh toi
je te tue tape ses 38 s'est bloqué et
des cheveux tulle non non mais oui c'est
ça allait avance non non ah mais je me
fais harceler mais [ __ ] mais non naam
sortait mais qu'est ce que je vous ai
fait quand j'ai tué toute votre famille
ou quoi bon c'est vrai j'ai peut-être
tué tous deux familles en fait j'ai tué
tellement de bestioles sur cette île
comme un avis j'ai complètement foutu en
l'air l'écosystème et ah ouais bon j'en
peux plus a su
news en fait pour avancer dans le jeu le
coeur du système sait les faire les
allers retours entre des personnages et
des endroits pour obtenir des objets qui
permet d'avancer
par exemple dans ce niveau à la fin on
va croiser une une péripatéticienne qui
nous demande d'aller chercher son
collier a le goût du continent
ok vite il te plait ouais c'est vrai
janina ya marqué chronopost sur ma
tunique verte
tu avais pas vu donc on doit les tuer
vraiment qu'ils sont collés il nous faut
qu'on lui ramène à vous donner une fiole
ah oui tu peux te donner carrément ouais
je demande vraiment si dans le cas des
changes du jeu et marquer personnage
moche
par exemple un corail blanc tu te dis
enfin c'est bon je vais parler une jolie
blonde c'est vrai tu vois là c'est une
grille de 19 ans de suède
mais quand tu lui parles si marie qods
incarne nos veines du bois de boulogne
et c'est pas évident - deux gardes l'ont
sérieux c'est censé être un personnage a
mis 15 ans on dirait jean ries le pen
disant femme rhea manteau magique
ce n'est pas grand chose mais cela te
permettra de transporter de l'eau
heureusement on a su elle sert beaucoup
un puisqu'on peut le remplir par exemple
la fonte des faits pour s'en servir
votre potion de vie quoi au moins on
peut reconnaître à céline claret
comprend les olives d'ocarina of time
c'est que pour récupérer de l'énergie
l'utilisent de l'eau poids parce que ça
ça m'a toujours fédérer dans les zelda
sont quatre livres lui pour recevoir
l'énergie et qui note des faits on rit
tension au niveau du temps comment
l'expliquer
[Musique]
autiste
afin de faciliter cette porte m et ça
vous a plu alors on continue
l'avantagé avec ce jeu c'est qu'il est
parfaitement linéaire et il devient plus
dur plus moche et de plus en plus
incohérent et évidemment un ca vaut
surtout pour la cohérence des tableaux
non mais je veux dire explique moi
l'utilité de mettre des ennemis comme ça
explique moi c'est j'ai une idée et si
on mettait des ennemis qui sont
immobiles donc ils savent à rien et on
l'aimé bien ami auteur d'un saut comme
ça il sent bien chiant à toucher tu vois
et surtout on va leur mettre 50 points
de vie de manière à ce que soient les
ennemis les plus lors du jeu a tué alors
tu vois comme ça ils sont immobiles ça
va rien et font chier tout le monde
c'est génial et c'est pareil pour le
rocher aussi tiens par exemple la
regarde et on va mettre un rocher là
qu'ils se cassent en une bombe et dix
mètres plus loin ont remis un second
rocher face à celui ci faudra pas qu'une
bombe pour le tuer il en faudra dix
comme ça trois tous les cons date air
qui vont tourner en rond dans tout le
jeu pour essayer de chercher un objet
magique pour péter le rocher alors qu en
fait y en a pas mais moi mon petit
plaisir c'était dans l'avant dernier
niveau 1 tu te tapes haut niveau qui est
méga lourds qui rempli d'ennemis qui te
bute en un coup quasiment tout ça pour
aller chercher une lanterne magique de
merde c'est l'objet des plus importants
du jeu qui te permet d'aller chez danone
et devinez qui vous la donne
sérieusement devinez qui enfin tu as eu
la vision pour trouver ma maison lui
seul petit pegi 18
voilà depuis le début le mec tu le
croises dans tous les niveaux alors
qu'en fait il assure lui l'objectif
cherche pour aller à la fin du jeu bon
allez vas-y ça va soulever la coupe je
sauvegarde
voilà et je continuerai bien allez c'est
bon
[Musique]
petit de son coeur de ce genre de sport
c'est génial j'ai hâte de tout
recommencer
[Musique]
encore un jeu qui va regretter de
l'avoir connu en retour les aventures et
c'est ainsi que le héros du salami
partie l aventure pour emprisonner le
mal une fois de plus ils vécu des
aventures fantastiques brava les
éléments affronta les pires jeux du
monde et les plus belles filles du
royaume s'arrachèrent les vêtements pour
lui ps n'allez pas croire que cette fin
est une ruse de flemmards pour pallier
au fait qu'on n'a pas eu le temps de la
tournée au fait qu'aucune fille n'a
réellement souhaité s'arracher les
vêtements pour nous
[Musique]